foreign
all right seeing that it's uh now past
10 uh I'm going to open the hearing on
SB 15 FN
and I'm going to look to representative
all right
uh yeah I was gonna make a motion sorry
represent a Cobalt for a motion uh OTP
on Senate Bill 15. okay and I'm going to
look for a second on that representative
two seconds
all right it's now uh OTP and open for
Amendment and I'm going to offer
and look for a second I will second
so we now have uh
the ability to discuss this amendment
I'm going to tell you that what this
amendment does is essentially remove the
written portion of the permission making
it just plain permission you can have it
in writing or verbal however you want
um because we did hear testimony that
um some landowners may be hesitant to
give
permission in writing because they think
they're taking on extra liability even
though they would be exempt from
liability but
I can see where there's a gray area on
that because you could if somebody comes
on your property hunting
when you're not don't have it posted
they are the the owner is exempt from
liability if they hurt themselves but if
you as a landowner invite someone onto
your property now there's a gray area
and and is that written permission an
invitation it could be considered such
in the court so I can see why some
landowners may want to just give verbal
permission I look at it as it's up to
the hunter if he wants to be in it he
said she said situation he really wants
to hunt the land uh he or she and and
there's uh if they want to hunt that
land in this and they're not going to
get written permission but they're
giving verbal permission it's up to them
to make that decision so uh written came
out verbal only or verbal or written up
to up to the landowner
um
what else did I put in the air uh change
instead of January 1st which gives them
more than 16 days I mean the archery
season ends on December 15th and then if
it has to be down by January 1st that's
really only 16 days for a hunter to go
gather all their tree stands in whatever
weather those 16 days throw at them in
December uh I think we kind of all can
agree that's not a safe situation to
send someone out climbing a tree in in
December to pull stands down
um so April 1st I think is a good date
um
we still kept the uh name and contact
information
needing to be put on the stand or blind
that allows say if the Timberland
Association one of their members is
going out to do a cut and they see a
tree stands there they at least know how
to contact
have it taken down
and I've added the whole section on who
who's allowed to remove the tree stand
because that was missing from here
um
there was there was no
the camera Bill had a clause about who's
allowed to remove it so we I just took
that same paragraph from the camera Bill
and put it in here so that we have
actually said that fish and game will
remove it or direct the owner and we
heard from the colonel that if Fish and
Game instructs the owner then that
removes liability from the owner for
damage because they've been told been
directed by Fish and Game so that's in
there now
and effective date chance to January 1st
because we know that we can't do a
shorter effective date when rules have
did I miss anything
I think that's it
so is there any other discussion on the
amendment questions or comments
I think this is yeah there it is
um concerning the
um taking down of the tree stand on
April 1st instead of
um at the end of December beginning of
January
can you please tell me how tree stands
are attached I had a phone call from a
constituent who is concerned because
sometimes they're attached by webbing
and leaving them up through the winter
the webbing might rot and then when you
go to stand on the tree stand it can
fall and you can get hurt and Sue the
landowner can somebody clarify that for
me please
I have many tree stands and uh it really
depends on the type of tree stand if
it's a climbing stand it's usually a
cable a plastic wrapped steel cable
not always but it usually is if you are
using a
ladder type tree stand that typically
has ratchet straps and those are weather
resistant and good form many years I can
tell you I've had the tree stand in
place on lands that I have permission to
hunt that's been up for
three years I checked the webbing of the
strap the uh the ratchet strap every
year and loosen it and adjust it as
needed with the tree growth replace it
when necessary but that's a standard
part of having the tree stand and
keeping your stand in in good working
condition it does not degrade over one
winter
if somebody else has a different opinion
I certainly would entertain it but
that's what I would answer that
thank you
any other questions representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman um
my feeling with ratchet straps I've I've
used them for years A lot of it depends
on
the UV so if it's on one side of the
tree versus another it may have
different uh characteristics of how long
they last so maybe that's some part of
it I don't know but UV seems to be the
thank you any other comments or
questions
yes I was uh interested in section 4
line 14.
um
and really it's on line 15 the permittee
shall carry such a permit on this person
if it's a if it's a verbal or not
written
so I can help you with this we're adding
the new information into current law and
current law as you can see already
requires written for anything permanent
anything that punctures a tree or a pit
blind or blind that has been dug into
the ground or uses cut trees
um where we've added the new section
that requires permission but not
necessarily written permission only for
those portable tree stands and blinds so
there is still a need to tell them about
carrying written permission if they have
it for those other instances where they
may have a permanent tree stand or blind
seeing none I will ask the clerk to call
all right let's see if I've got all the
representative goalie
yes
representative merner
representative kofault yes
representative Tudor
representative naughter yes
representative Brown is yes
representative Hill yes
who am I missing
representative Boyd yes
representative Harvey no
representative Reed yes
representative damond yes
oh sorry representative Ford see I
didn't get it right I am glad I asked
yes representative Fox yes
representative massamila
representative Morton
yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative pair
in the chair and yes Chairman's Blaine
yes thank you
I have 18 years one nay and one absent
anyone okay anyone object to consent for
this
oh that was the amendment sorry
all right we're on the otpa now
um and we're open to discussion on otpa
does anybody have any questions or
comments on otpa right now on the bill
oh
well okay we need to redo the motion now
for otpa because we uh we need to have
uh representative Reed Mr chair I move
otpa
we have a second
I will second that
okay it's been moved and seconded
discussion on otpa on the entire Bill
any questions comments I do who was that
second sorry that was a cold fault thank
you
okay seeing none I'll have the chair the
uh representative goalie
yes
representative Khan absent
representative murder yes representative
co-fault yes representative Tudor
yes representative naughter yes
representative Brown yes representative
Hill yes
representative renzullo
representative Boyd yes
representative Harvey yes representative
Reed
yes representative Ford yes
yes representative of where are my fox
yes oh boy representative massamila yeah
representative Morton yes representative
O'Brien yes
representative pair
representative rosener yes
chairman Spillane yeah yes
we have 19 years zero Nays and one
absent one notebook everyone okay with
consent I assume we are going to put
that on consent
and the motion was made by
Representative no representative Reed
Reed representative Reed would you like
sure I was being polite by asking
because you were the one who made the
motion
please have that to the uh clerk by
I'm closing the hearing on SB 15 and
opening the hearing on sb14
and I will entertain a motion from
representative Tudor
Mr chair I move that we retain sb14
it's been moved to retain do we have a
second yes a second that
it's been moved and seconded
it's now open for discussion do we have
representative Reed
thank you Mr chair so uh I've been
somewhat torn about this I am a complete
believer in the ability for people to
maintain their privacy I do understand
that we don't want to necessarily move
to the Midwest Model I believe also in
our New Hampshire model of
until a land is posted treating private
land as public land because that I don't
believe in anybody who knows me knows
this uh I don't believe in complete
power given to people on the basis
solely of what they own
however
um I think we need to work on this
further because I am I'm very concerned
about privacy and especially
um into the extent that people might be
stalked they might have I mean there's
more than More Creeps than I would like
in the world and that's something that
concerns me so I think we need to work
further on this
okay uh representative Tudor
yeah I should speak to my motion for a
second is that we have doing amendments
we have displaying Amendment and we have
the goal the amendment I just think that
we had a work session with later in the
term uh we could look at the good points
of both these amendments and try to
merge them into a single Amendment we
kind of have the issue of does the Honda
need permission from the landowner to
put up a camera or does the landowner
have to post his land to say I don't
want you to put up a camera and in a big
issue with I think needs to be resolved
is
um for those folks that have property
and current use Recreation if I then
choose to put up a sign that restricts
the use of my property which violates
current use Recreation
um do I then lose my 20 tax break that I
get for allowing anybody to come on my
property and hunt fish uh bird watch
whatever they want to do so I just think
there's a lot of things we could do to
make this bill better and clarify things
and uh it would be worthwhile to work on
a little bit more
thank you representative Tudor
representative goalie
thank you Mr chair I will be voting
against the retaining motion
um as said we have two amendments before
us
two amendments that we heard in the
public hearing of issues that needed to
be addressed
I put forward an amendment that I worked
with those folks
and drafted
posting your property for prohibiting
use of cameras has anything to do with
the current use tax credit
I don't see anything in law that
prohibits that and I'm sure there's some
folks out there that know the law very
well that are big landowners that could
address that so I don't think that's an
issue
what an issue is is
having somebody put a piece of
surveillance equipment on your property
is an issue
and these pieces of equipment now aren't
like what they used to be where you had
to go in the woods pull a card out
and actually take it home to download
the images you had
these cameras do lifetime video and
photos
of your property whether you're a
hundred feet from your house or you're a
thousand feet from your house walking a
trail on your property that you own
pictures can be taken real time and
the amendment before us will address
so I ask that you vote against the
retain
respect the landowners rights
I know I wouldn't want somebody
having a camera on my property on a
walking trail if I own 25 acres and I'm
out well beyond my house walking the
property and they put it on a tree that
I don't see it watching me every morning
walk my property without my permission
so I'm not voting for The retain I hope
the rest of you will follow me and let's
pass on it past this landowner's Bill of
Rights here that gives them the respect
of their property as to what's put on it
thank you
thank you representative uh
representative Harvey
I will be voting against the retention
as well
the emails that I've been receiving
um
indicate that landowners are concerned
about cameras being placed on their
property without any identification and
what they then think they might do to
protect their land and themselves is
simply post the land so therefore
there's going to be less and less land
available for hunters and those of us
that do support ethical hunting that's
not what we want to see happen so I will
be voting against the retention so we
can discuss discuss the motions and and
also respect the wishes and the rights
of landowners thank you
thank you representative any further
representative uh Brown uh thank you Mr
chairman
um
interestingly enough as I sit through
this as a freshman I see so often we
have a bill somewhere
and someone says well this isn't quite
right and the committee goes ahead and
sends it on and we hope it's going to be
fixed by someone else later this has
already come to us so I I am I am for
the Chairman's Amendment except for the
300 feet based on my constituencies
concerns about privacy as a
representative Golian representative
Harvey said however
I am all in favor of the peace about the
current use land and as
representative goalie said if we aren't
clear on that
I'm sure there's someone out there that
knows the answer as you said but if we
aren't clear on this current use piece
and if there's anything we're not clear
in about this
let's get it right before we take it to
the house floor and before we move it on
um I I am and again I'm following my
constituents wishes that they they do
want privacy for their property there's
no question
um but let's get this let's bring it to
the floor solidly and make sure we have
thank you representative
I hate this because the reason that I
wanted to support retain is because I
think we can make posting easier for
people which is something I've worked on
before but we just passed on consent
needing permission for a tree stand a
camera is the amplification of the
ability to surveil which is much worse
than a tree stand in my mind so I I
can't imagine why we wouldn't require
permission for that
um so those are my thoughts right now
and that's all I have to say
just as chair I'm going to clarify that
what we passed on consent for the tree
stands did not require permission for
any placement only for placing beyond
uh representative goalie
thank you Mr chair
we have a number of folks in the
audience and I wanted to see if we could
get their take on current use and if
posting with game cameras would affect
current use status they are the
Timberland owners and they know very
well what the laws are and how they are
enforced
is there someone from the Timberland
Association that would like to speak to
the current use I know that there's a
list currently of things that are
allowed to be posted for such as ohrv
and such
uh my intent with the amendment that I
drafted was to add cameras to that list
so that it was a definite exemption and
nobody could ever lose that 20 percent
but if somebody wants to speak to
whether that's clear or not already
so for for the record I'm Jason stock
the executive director of the New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
in
I'm reviewing this language now
um
on the Fly here
so as I understand it and correct me if
I'm wrong you would not be eligible for
the 20
reduction uh in your assessment if you
disallow game cameras is that what this
no this is saying that
even if you post your land that says no
game cameras allowed you'd still get
your 20 percent
because currently uh the current use
says that you can that you're not going
to lose your 20 if you post against
motorized vehicles like ohrvs
snowmobiles and such but that's the only
exemption if if you post against
somebody hiking you lose your 20 if you
post against hunting you lose your 20 so
what I wanted to do and what this
language does is ADS uh game cameras
into the list of things you're allowed
to post for and still keep your twenty
percent
okay thank you yeah I I guess
right now the way the the current use
law is structured and Rob this thing
just went to sleep on me
all right thank you it's but it and
really the focus is pedestrian and
pedestrian access
ohrvs that's correct you I mean ohrvs
are kind of a if it's motorized they
have they are obligated to get
permission but currently
there shall be no prohibition on skiing
snowshoeing fishing hunting hiking or
nature observation
and so that's really you know that's the
the universe for the recreational
recreational discount if you were to say
you know and to me game cameras
I guess I I find this discussion
actually a little bit odd because it's
not really a pedestrian I'm placing
something on your piece of property it's
it's a
Act of placing something not skiing or
snowshoeing I'm not sure this is even
necessary candidly I mean I appreciate
the intent if if I post against game
cameras and I can remain in current use
and eligible for the recreational
discount fine I'm I'm fine with that
but again to me the way current use is
structured is it really focuses on the
use and not placement of something on my
on my property I.E camera or or tree
yeah I kind of question the need need
for this but I do appreciate the attempt
and and you know if I if I post against
game cameras and I'm and I continue to
remain in the current use 20
recreational discount
that's fine I'm I'm fine with that I
mean as long as I can continue to get my
20 assessment discount for recreation
if I post against game cameras
um
I'm trying to think here it's almost
like a double negative
yeah yeah I mean
I'm not going to lose I'm not going to
lose anything if I say no game cameras
is I guess is the way I read this now I
I don't know if there's other
interpretations and again kind of
reading this and interpreting it on the
Fly is a little bit
tricky
um
so I'm kind of questioning whether it's
even necessary candidly because
it's it's not snowshoeing it's not
you know it's not a pedestrian activity
really
that's those are my my thoughts on a
five-minute review and and kind of
discussion about current use assessment
as it relates to the recreational
I mean
not to not to even I don't think it's
relevant in some respects but
nevertheless so try to answer any
questions
so I I have one more when when these
determinations on whether you have
violated current use come down it's the
local assessor who who determines that
and then you have to appeal it if
they've done so correct yeah so it's so
every local assessor may have a
different opinion on what uh might or
might not violate that and so
proactively telling them they cannot
remove it if you do this at least
codifies that and locks it down correct
they sure that I I guess in that respect
it may be helpful
um but again I just I don't
I I kind of question it the need for it
to begin with thank you for your time
today thank you representative Hill you
had a question I do uh of the chair
um procedurally
I I don't know why we're talking about
two amendments that have not been
introduced
um it would seem to me we're the
question on the floor is retain of the
original bill yeah we did drift a little
bit we were I mean the purpose of the
retain was to try to combine amendments
so there was allowed some discussion of
why we might want to combine those
amendments or work on a solution that
takes from both
um that was the intent from the
representative who made the retention
motion so uh but I think we probably are
done with that
[Music]
um
representative nodder
um I don't have the original bill in
front of me are these amendments
significantly different than the
it depends on what you consider
significant
they are different
um but the changes are if we get to
those amendments being introduced you'll
just a follow-up follow-up well because
if they're very different they may
require a public hearing they're not
significantly different enough for a
public hearing but well that would be an
is there any other comments questions oh
representative Brown
uh thank you Mr chair so I'll jump in
again even even uh uh Mr stock
uh comments
yeah it still isn't 100 clear and we
heard from a number of
uh people testifying that there was
concern about the the current of loss of
that piece of their current use I think
it's it's a really important thing and I
think we should uh I'm gonna still say
we should retain this
thank you representative do we have any
again Mr chair a vice chair sorry thank
you Mr chair
and I I will just make a comment that
if someone chooses not to allow tree
stands there's nothing in a lot of
prohibiting the posting of no tree
stands
and I don't see how that would be any
different as to being posted put into
current news statute
um I think it was pretty clear that
the post the current use has to deal
with traveling through property and
being allowed on property not putting
personal
property of another on someone else's
property I'll leave it at that
thank you Mr Vice chair
any other further comments questions
before we go to the vote on retain
being none I'll let the clerk call the
roll
representative goalie excuse me
no
representative Khan is absent
representative merner
yes
representative kovalt yes representative
Tudor yes
representative naughter yes
representative Brown is yes
representative Hill yes
representative nutting
oh wait razulo yes
sorry representative Boyd yes
representative Harvey
no
representative Reed
representative Fox no
representative massimilla
representative Morton no
representative O'Brien no
representative pair
representative Rosner
no
uh Chairman's Blaine
yes
I'm correct we have nine years ten Nays
and one no vote motion fails
nine to ten
uh
bill is now open to further Amendment
I'm going to offer Amendment
oh that's right
do we have a motion of ought to pass
I'll move out to pass do we have a
second
I will second
it's been moved and seconded it's now
open to further amendment I will offer
Amendment 1466.
do I have a second
second
it's been moved and seconded
I will discuss my Amendment uh
and then we'll open it up to questions
and discussion
so this amendment
um
tries to strike a balance between the
privacy of the landowners and the
traditional uh hunting
by restricting cameras from anywhere
within 300 feet of a building or a
driveway
but allowing the cameras on other parts
of property
unless the person who owns the property
puts a sign up
to post No cameras they do not need to
post the whole land just one sign at the
entrance to the property or any number
of entrances at the property
um
it also changes the fine down to a
hundred dollars from the Thousand that
um
and changes the effective date to
January 1st
and it also specifically says that the
first violation of of the uh
any camera displaced illegally would be
a warning to let people know that they
shouldn't be doing that
give everybody a first chance to realize
that they did something wrong
and
that I believe is the extent of oh and I
changed it from written permission to
regular permission
and then I've added the whole section on
the current use to make sure that it's
codified and no local assessor can come
and say well in my opinion in my reading
of it a camera is used for
um
Wildlife viewing
and so you posted it against cameras so
we're going to take away your uh current
use
by codifying it we've basically drawn
the line and said that I don't care what
you think is a personal assessor for
this town we've said as a state level
that that cameras can be prohibited just
like ohrvs and you must still let them
have their 20 discount
I look at it as proactive
and making sure that somebody's right to
that discount is not infringed by their
wish to not have cameras on their
property and that's all I have on that
oh yeah uh same hunting day that was the
other change
the remote cameras were the the original
Bill had the uh the remote cameras
restricted 24 hours that becomes a
problem because if you put if you get a
picture of a deer right before uh sunset
and it's 24 hours that means you can't
hunt there the whole next day
because you've gotten it
uh 24 hours
so same hunting day if you get it before
Sunset and the hunting day ends
you can still go hunt there tomorrow and
I'm pretty sure the deer is not still
going to be standing there the next day
right so I think that that gives plenty
of time
the whole night
we've gone into a new hunting day and
unless the deer is dumb enough to wait
around for you he's not going to be
standing there in the same spot so that
was another important change to to fix
the Senate version
and that's all I've got uh anybody got
thank you uh I think you missed one
other to me very significant change
between the bill that was presented from
the Senate and your Amendment uh it's in
section 2A of the original Amendment yes
it's still section 2A on your own on
your Amendment so line 11 of the
amendment says a person may place a game
camera that records et cetera et cetera
Etc uh in the bill presented from the
Senate it says no person shall place a
game camera that records transmits etc
etc without the written consent of the
property owner
correct that's because we added the
section that says where they're
prohibited from doing it without the
permission is 300 feet of any building
on the property or any driveway
so so you're we're allowing it still if
it's deep in the woods or far enough
away from a house to be put there
without permission
but if it's within the 300 feet it must
have the permission
and I consider this to be a small step
forward to changing it and I think if
you know if it turns out that it wasn't
enough perfectly willing to come back
with another bill uh that further
restricts it but I like to take things
in small steps when you're taking away
uh a traditional way of of surveilling
deer and and patterning them and hunting
I think that the smaller steps taken
gradually to alleviate the problems
better than taking and
completely changing the way things go
um and I would I would liken it to not
amputating an arm when you can just
follow-up all right I think that if we
make
um
what I consider a significant change
by Amendment from that which was
presented to the public because the
public testimony was all based on the
you can't put out a camera unless you
get permission and all the responses I
have seen have been very much in favor
of that then I think we have to go back
to public hearing
but we are not changing the way the
current law is
this is just simply this change in the
amendment puts it back to the way it is
now
the Senate's version of wording was
turning what the way it works now
on its head
so this is going back that whole section
is just being reverted to the way it
currently is
you currently do not need permission to
go on anyone's property and put a camera
on it that's what we're trying to fix
because right now you can put it
anywhere
and I'm trying to say let's limit it
within 300 feet of any building or
driveway first
and I specifically added the driveways
in because we heard testimony that
um people might put a camera up to watch
when somebody comes and goes and then
burgle the house
seems reasonable to me we want to
enhance the privacy but I'm trying to
strike a balance with this amendment to
not completely change all the hunting
rules right away let's take a small step
forward in my opinion
[Music]
um
I've got some hands down here first
representative Ford
thank you Mr chairman uh I I appreciate
the balance as most people know I prefer
balance over anything
um I guess my biggest concern is the 300
feet of occupied building or dwelling
um I live in the city so 300 feet is no
big deal right but occupy dwelling
concerns me because I imagine my
colleagues at work or friends that I
have across the state they have a barn
or a shed or something that may be more
than 300 feet away from their house and
then if we say that building doesn't
count so you can put a camera near that
shed or building because it's not
occupied
that now and someone can surveillance
that particular piece of building on
this person's property even though it's
not occupied so that's my biggest
concern and then
um
two I think the
effective date
gives gives enough time that people will
know
um when if we don't change the bill
people will have enough time to know
they need to get permission but it's the
300 feet from the Occupy dwelling that
concerns me because if it's occupied of
course you don't want to have a camera
facing your house or near your house but
if you have other pieces or buildings on
your property that you also don't want
people to surveillance that is a concern
for me
it does that make sense it makes sense
and I asked Colonel Jordan to step
forward to the microphone and explain
the fishing game uh uh interpretation of
occupied versus permanently occupied
so well it's not a fishing game it's
been done by the New Hampshire Supreme
Court
um and an occupied dwelling is a
dwelling that would allow for overnight
accommodations so you could have a camp
you could have a barn if it has a bed in
it
um I suppose would fit that description
so it's not something that we control is
something the Supreme Court uh denotes
so I do have one other comment that I
think is pretty important that people
understand here if I can make it on the
amendment
let me get to my other questions on the
committee before I come back to you for
that yeah it's a big it is a big issue
you can you can feel free to stay in the
seat because we might have other
questions thank you thank you
you're good yes thank you Jim
representative Reed
thank you Mr chair
I would also like to come in the chair
on what is for the most part I think a
very reasonable compromise
um
I so the 300 feet from an occupied
dwelling or driveway I I just imagine if
I had land and I had a pond that I liked
to Skinny Dip in or a clearing that I
wanted to sunbathe in
um that the occupied swelling wouldn't
cover that and again I I think it's
important to remember that while we talk
about these cameras in the context of
hunting it's not just hunting it's
anyone can put a camera up your ex could
come and put a camera up without
permission
um so and you know we can talk about the
hunting aspect and what is traditional
surveillance because when when the
common is made that it traditionally
surveilled by camera while traditional
hunting would be going out into the
woods and creating your own bow and
arrow and then carving your own
Arrowhead so uh you know what is
traditional but
um but it's not just hunting we can have
Fair Chase conversation but it's not
just hunting it's anything and so the
the part of this amendment that gives me
the most pause
is the idea that the first violation is
has to be a warning because that takes
away the
um the ability for the justice system to
determine whether or not that was
maliciously done or accidentally done uh
which is what they have the ability to
determine now and and pursue that
accordingly as to what makes sense for
that situation and this is saying no
even if it was my ex that put a camera
on my property in such a way as to
surveil me that that would still have to
be just a warning and that bothers me so
thank you representative and
representative Harvey
um so
um I have a lot of trouble with the 300
feet
um right now you can't fire within 300
feet of a building anyway so
that doesn't mean too much
um and again in talking to my
constituents
they want written permission rather the
cameras within 300 feet or not within
300 feet and again they're
remedy is then well then I just will
post my land and we'll have less land
for hunting I actually
um I agree with representative Reed
um
I don't have a problem with the fine uh
being levied the first time around we're
talking about somebody's privacy here
that you can't just say to them oh
please don't do that again that wasn't
very nice
um it it really needs to have some teeth
to it so I don't have a problem with
that
um with the fine being lovey the first
time around I even like the thousand
dollars
um but my my biggest thing is um I I
want written permission no matter where
you put the camera on somebody's private
representative Rosner
yeah I want to Second a lot of everybody
else's spoken concerns about the 300
feet
um I think when it comes to a person's
property
um people are within their rights if
they own this space to say yeah as long
as you stay away from this certain
allotted space but if it is your
property and first and foremost it's
your
um your things to do whatever you want
to do in that space
um I think it makes a lot of sense that
whereas anything else that is public
people can go and do whatever they want
that if it is owned land by a specific
person they get to denote what they do
and do not want other people other
strangers doing on their land and I
think it makes sense in the sense of if
we approach this as it is just Good
Samaritan citizens hunting
um but I think that it becomes an issue
when we look at this from the standpoint
that this is state law and anybody who
can go and spend Thirty forty dollars on
a camera can do whatever they want
outside of 300 feet of an occupied space
um I don't want to kind of reiterate
everything that everyone else has said
but I think it's important
um I like the idea that a landowner
could denote
what they feel is their standard and not
have it regulated by the state what that
standard has to be for them whether or
not they're going to be able to get that
Etc
um and I also
um think again the um
the the warning and the fee I I don't
know if I agree with how standardized
that is I think that on a case-by-case
basis that needs a little bit more
wiggle room to
um address every situation specifically
because again uh innocent accident is
very different than what is not a an
innocent accident
thank you representative any further
comments or questions on the panel
I'll go with the vice chair first and
then we'll follow up with you
representative
thank you Mr chair I too cannot support
the 300 feet he heard testimony from
numerous people out there
and
these landowners don't own just two or
three acres
they own 40 50 one 200 Acres pieces of
property that big enough to have a small
pond on
a family Cemetery
trails that they hold sacred that maybe
a loved one we heard is their ashes may
be spread upon
that they may not want to be filmed or
videoed and have posted online
I think they have that right
and they shouldn't have to post their
property to say it's not right to put a
camera into video of this
they just have the ability to say no
I'll allow you to put a camera on but
please don't put it where
and you know I think representative Reed
made a great point when she talked about
you know the swimming or whatever and
like I said these big pieces of property
many do have ponds
where things like this take place
this wouldn't prohibit a camera from
there
so I can't support this I think it needs
to be a permission and strictly
permission if you're going to surveil a
property thank you
thank you representative representative
Harvey I I would just like to ask if
Colonel Jordan would please be allowed
to make his comment especially since he
said it was very important and I always
um respect Colonel Jordan's comments
thank you
and he will I'm just trying to make sure
that all of the discussion here gets to
take place in case there's more
questions for him so we can have him
address them all at the same time
any further comments or questions
representative Brown and thank you Mr
chair just to remind everyone we had the
conversation about the thousand dollar
fine during the hearings and there was
some concern that even though it said up
to theoretically someone with 10 cameras
could get fined a thousand dollar for
each camera and that although it may
sound great to have a thousand dollar
fine to really stop
something that you don't want the
potential is to find somebody ten
thousand dollars if they had ten cameras
and that was why I think on both sides
any further comments or questions
Colonel Jordan
so a couple things I really appreciate
the discussion and the interest in
recognizing what was testified to by
landowners because I think it's very
important and I commend both these
amendments for trying to do that
um so two two comments that I would like
to make that are that are concerning
about this particular one first one is
the discretion of officers so that is a
hurdle we as managers at least I have as
the chief of law enforcement have
struggled with because I'll have one
individual officer who will issue a
warning for a certain offense and
another one issues uh Citation for that
offense and I've thought of getting a
better handle of controlling that maybe
writing a policy that required them to
write tickets instead of warnings and
and what I found was exactly what
representative Reed commented to is you
can't it's very difficult to do that
it's almost impossible to do that
because the intent of the offense
changes with every individual person so
someone may in fact just make a mistake
and in that case that is appropriate for
a warning where other people may be
intentionally filming someone who and
they've been warned not to do that and
that would tie my hands to not be able
to address that and I can't imagine
facing facing an ex-wife for instance
who was videotaped by her ex-husband
during a divorce and me telling her that
I can't do anything except give him a
warning so I I certainly appreciate what
representative spleen is trying to
accomplish I will tell you this sir that
our staff I'm very confident when I tell
you that at least my staff I can speak
for is very good at that I think and I
have found if I sit quietly and keep my
mouth shut that they do an outstanding
job with Discerning that and I worry
about trying to regulate that more
importantly the one paragraph here that
really disturbs me is paragraph starts
on 2A per line 11. we've put in the bill
now we've so it will be in law that says
a person may place a camera that records
or transmits image images or data of any
kind while unattended outside on the
private property of another without
written consent of the property owner
the problem that that's going to create
is I now do not have the authority when
the landowner calls me and says I don't
want that on my property you need to go
remove it I can't do that because the
law allows for it that's concerning
because now you've taken away all rights
of our property owners and I don't think
that was representative spleen's intent
I certainly don't think that was but if
you put that in this law that's exactly
what's going to happen is I will be we
will be powerless to remove it I don't
think we ever want to do that so those
are the two things that and I thank you
for your indulging me thank you colonel
I will just uh make a comment that
I wish we had been able to retain this
so that we could uh continue working on
it I think that if we could come back to
that motion at some point today I think
it's probably a better way to go because
I I really also want to point out that
that requiring somebody to get
when they the the land is not posted
could be abused by people who just don't
want people of a certain type on their
property
and I'm going to point out that you know
it
if I go and ask a landowner for
permission and I'm granted permission
for the camera and somebody who looks
different than me or sounds different
than me or doesn't have uh drive a truck
as nice as mine goes up and tries to ask
for this permission and is denied I
think we're opening ourselves for a
little bit of a problem here with uh
people not getting the same
opportunities as others
um and I'd hate to see that happen but
that's where
I stand on it and um
I guess if there's no other comments
from anybody we'll go ahead and ask the
representative goalie
no
representative con sent representative
merner
is
representative cofult yes
representative Tudor
yes
representative Nutter yes
representative Brown is a no
representative Hill
yes
representative nutting
uh sorry I keep
representative renzullo
so sorry representative Boyd yes
representative Harvey
no representative Reed no representative
Ford
representative
FOX NOW representative massimilla
representative Morton no
representative O'Brien no
representative pair
representative Rosner no
no all right if my math is right we have
78 uh chairman Spillane I keep
uh years eight Nays 11 no vote one
Amendment fails and the OTP motion is
what we're back at and it's open to
further Amendment
sure I'd like to make motion move
Amendment 1446h
chair recognizes the vice chair making a
motion of uh offering Amendment 1446 H
amendment
1446h has been moved and seconded I'll
let the vice chair speak to his
Amendment
this amendment makes
some of the same changes yours made as
well as a few others
um
this allows for uh no person she'll take
game animal or Fair bearing animal
within the same calendar day for the
also uh
ads in online 14 and 15 that a game
camera placed on state-owned or managed
lands or are municipally owned property
which we heard would needed to be
addressed so that adds into that section
as well
um
basically the same the camera is going
to be labeled
uh removed from a
[Music]
conservation officer they need to be
contacted
and changes the fine to up to 125
dollars for each offense it gets instead
of a thousand dollars which I think we
all heard was a an issue and it changes
the effective date uh just like yours to
January 1st 2024 so rules can be
implemented
thank you Mr Vice chair are there any
comments and questions representative
Hill
uh Mr chair would it be possible to ask
for a 10-minute caucus
we could do that with the vice chair
like to caucus with his people as well
okay we will uh
actually we can go down to room
300a we'll go down to Janine's office
and we'll do our caucus there where
okay it's uh ten past and we're back to
goodness
excuse me we left off with discussions
on uh Amendment 1446 were there any
further discussions to be had before we
okay
uh yes representative Brown nope okay
I'm asking you to give me a second
that's
I'll talk while you're organizing
representative Reed thank you
um I actually think I prefer the Senate
Amendment
um I don't have a problem with Hunters
having to wait 24 hours after taking an
image
uh so I think I'll just be going with
the Senate version
representative Ford
thank you chairman uh I just want to
make it note that I was for us to caucus
because I was taken aback by the
potential of uh discrimination based on
the on the property owners bias
um but after uh talking with my
colleagues understanding that we have
federal and state regulations that help
folks when it comes to discrimination or
if they felt they were discriminated
against
um and so I just want to make that clear
and appreciate representative goalie and
his uh amendment to this to make it more
clear
um for what should happen with game
anybody else I have a point of
information
representative Brown correct me if I'm
wrong you said 1446 but I think we're 14
20. no 1446.
is it an old Amendment
I gave you a sec
okay all right good thank you
we have everyone back in the room yes we
do okay
all right I'm going to ask the clerk to
all right everybody pay attention we're
going to change this a little bit
no
representative goalie
yes
representative Khan
representative merner
no
representative Tudor
no Representative naughter no
representative Brown no representative
Representative rizzulo no
we're in Zulo representative Boyd no
representative Harvey
yes representative Reed
no
representative Fox yes
representative massamila
representative Morton yes representative
O'Brien yes
representative pair
all right eight years 11 Nays one no
vote
Amendment fails we're back to OTP on the
original bill as written
uh representative Rosner
forgive my freshmanness but um
would I be able to ask for a motion for
retain
you could actually reconsider I think we
have to dispense with the OTP first or
we can ask that the emotions for OTB be
withdrawn so that a reconsideration
could be taken and then we could go back
to OTP if needed
uh who made the original second in
motion on the OTP Mr clerk I didn't
I believe I need the second on the OTP
and unfortunately I didn't record that I
have cold
and you did it okay thank you so
co-fault was second and and uh the vice
chair was was the motion
I will withdraw my second
okay and would you be willing to
withdraw your motion of OTP so that uh
Rosner could reconsider
Mr chair I'm going to stick with my
motion of art to pass
um I try to work a compromise here and I
don't see that going forward the Senate
sent us a bill that
landowners have asked for
it deals with the surveillance of
property I think we had unfortunately
two amendments in front of us
to address and specifically one to
address the uh surveillance of property
and property rights this will go ahead I
don't think landowners want to wait any
longer
um on putting a stop to surveilling
property without written permission or
without permission
so I will
keep my motion and hopefully get a
second from someone to take a vote on
representative Harvey I'll second it
we have another second but it's been
thrown on the floor for it
representative nodder first if the
octopass fails can it then go back to
okay
thank you Mr chair and I will state I
once again I don't think this bill needs
to be retained I think it's been vetted
stuff in front of us and the longer we
wait
the more surveillance is going on
without permission
whether it's on your local pond this
summer
or the back 40 that you may own
and
I'm willing to go forward with this now
representative Rosner
I just want to say that I'm I'm
completely happy with doing the OTP
um and then if that fails we do the
retain I did originally vote to retain
um and I will vote OTP on the SB but I
felt as though we as a body here are
really not on the same page so
um our vote on OTP I'm happy to do uh
and happy to see that that comes first I
just wanted to clarify my my reason for
bringing up retain and um
not necessarily knowing how that process
works thank you
representative Tudor
yeah I just think to ought to pass this
at this point um I mean I wasn't at the
public hearing but I did watch the tapes
and there were numerous issues brought
up about this bill about the Senate bill
and that's the reason why we wrote the
two amendments and just just a punt and
go back to the Senate bill I think is
the wrong thing to do I think we should
be you know kill the auth to pass and
then go back and reconsider the retain
so we can actually work on this thing
and make it better because it's not
going to matter about your Pawn this
summer this bill isn't going into effect
until January no matter what we do so we
have time to work on it and still get it
out there for the next hunting season
because that's really what this bill is
thank you
um representative
thank you Mr chair
um
I think we've all been on the receiving
end of the emails there have been
multiple emails from many landowners
constituents they would like to see us
act on game cameras and
needing permission to put game cameras
on property
um
were all in agreement
the Senate has sent us a bill that will
do that
I think at this point it would
be neglectful not to
Vice chair
thank you Mr chair I just got to respond
to the
in putting this off
it won't be ready for January 1st 2024
we're looking at now we're in May during
January 1st 2024. we retain this we
won't be back here until November
December voting on these so it won't be
in place anytime close to that by the
time rules are put in place
so yes time is of the essence thank you
thank you
um yes representative Fox
thank you Mr chairman just one quick
note that the Senate bill is written uh
it takes effect 60 days after it's
passed so that one would be quicker than
what's
being proposed with January 1st the next
year
representative Brown I I have two
um I think that issue of the passage in
60 days was discussed in the public
hearing that that was probably not a
follow-up thank you Mr chair
um I'll say it again I guess maybe this
is the Boy Scout piece coming out
why are we
approving something that we're all
seeming to say isn't ready yet I just
don't get it
there's let's put a committee together
and and work together I don't know what
representative goalie how he worked with
it and he told me he worked with the
groups I don't know exactly what that
conversation was we I I just can't s I
just can't send something along that we
have so many questions about
thank you
thank you anyone else
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
uh the motion is on the OTP no Amendment
think we've had too many votes here
right
do we need another sheet I know I got
them I just
dang
representative Ford while we're waiting
just to clarify we are
OTP the original Senate Bill no
amendments right that's the vote at the
moment because the amendments were
defeated okay so if the OTP is also
defeated we can then move back to
another motion for anything itl or
retain
all right thank you for that time Mr
chairman
uh we will start with
representative Koval no
representative goalie yes representative
Khan
representative Koval sorry sorry
representative noder I looked away from
the sheet for a second
no
representative Brown no
representative Hill
oh
representative
renzullo
representative boy no
uh representative Harvey
representative Reed
yes
representative massamila
representative Morton yes representative
page
uh
representative O'Brien oh see I get that
all right let me back up
let's do this again representative Ford
was yes representative Fox yes
had my representative Mesa Miller
representative Morton
yes representative O'Brien there we go
no yeah yes he was a
[Laughter]
sedative pair
and representative Rosner yes
all right if you forgot me Mr uh and
chairman Spillane representative
representative tutors know
oh it does okay and represent and
Chairman's Blaine no
are we good
no
everyone thinks it's easy until they
maybe I did this maybe he did vote
clarification I thought I voted no but
he over there evidently heard yes I did
thank you
all right just just for clarity let me
um representative kofault
no
representative goalie yes
representative Mariner no there it is
okay
he had to find the one he was missing
sorry
thank you so we have 10 yes 9 no and one
no Amendment
and the motion was made by the Vice
chair so he will be writing the blurbs
they're going to be a minority blurb
written
[Laughter]
okay uh so I will be doing the minority
on that one and goalie's got the
majority yep you will get the majority
from
uh
what are we doing on the 12th is that
the uh oh yeah owl Brooks we got so many
Replacements here today but for anybody
who's uh who's an actual member of the
committee does anybody have any
questions about the owl Brook coming up
on the 12th do we have anybody who's
definitely going to be there or
definitely isn't going to be there
you're still not getting emails
I don't know what's going on with that
I'm going
how about a show of hands for uh the
vice chair so he can
the only thing I know is just from what
you said Alan Brooke from the 12th
yeah there's a thing at Al Brook and I'm
in
okay let me know okay all right so
so we're working with Des to get a a
boat trip on the river not Out on the
Ocean but up on the piscatica river to
look at the proposed uh boat ramp and
launch the fishing games wants uh the
D.O.T wants to put in on Hilton Park and
an opportunity to see a uh an oyster
farming operation and how they do that
which is really interesting if you've
never seen it uh Des has got a 35-foot
boat and Fish and Game might bring one
of their boats um
still working on the date there it had
to go it had to go up the chain to the
important people and they haven't talked
so when we get a date we'll we'll work
on that but uh I wanted to let people
know we're not going to hear the bill on
the boat ramp that went over to uh
Public Works
um so even though it's it's a boat ramp
for fish and game activities it's going
to public works because they deal with
boat ramps but we can still see where
they're planning to put it
um and thank you again everyone have a
great rest of the day and we'll see you